hey folks we might be drunks brought to
you by sheath the official underwear of
Comedy I bet I'm wearing them right now
yeah
what's a better uh promo than that I'm
not but I usually am no he's wearing
panties U.S army soldier Robert Patton
knew there to be a better way to keep
your dicks from sticking to your leg and
she was born every pair of sheath is a
soft flexible cradle-like pouch that
separates the boys from the inner thigh
eliminating sticky situations I love
them they look great they feel great you
got to get the balls in the dick a
little space it's like Israel and
Palestine down there sheath comes in a
lot of patterns and they're ready for
any occasion they didn't leave out the
ladies either we got boy shorts sports
bras and bikini briefs go to
sheathunderwear.com use promo code drunk
to get 20 off your first order every
order comes with sheets 100 money back
guarantee that's sheathunderwear.com
promo code drunk get sheath underwear
and let them support your balls
[Music]
hey folks we're here we might be garbage
yeah we are garbage yeah yeah we all are
we're drinking the day
this is the Saint Patty's Day
Extravaganza with the ru garbage guy I
love it man I'm so excited oh yeah you
you guys are must be some some Mick yeah
Irish Catholic trash uh-huh wow although
my mom did do a 23andMe a couple of
years ago no black a Muslim what was the
weirdest thing you got in there uh she
did it there might be a connection with
some people that we didn't know we were
related to Jericho I'll leave that I'll
leave that no not even that just uh
dirty WAP might have been some
hanky-panky going on
oh baby duck trashy soap opera down
there all right my dad's my mom my mom's
my dad I don't know who my brother is
I'll tell you that's Chinatown baby
all right I did the 23andMe and it's the
coolest part is you get weird [__] like
it'll tell you what your taste buds are
like and I'm like yeah it's like you
prefer Savory to Sweet and I'm like
that's [__] true I don't think that's
a good thing I don't know when
everybody's doing it for Christmas I was
like listen let sleeping dogs lie you
don't want to know what's what don't go
digging yeah you are who you are that's
it I know one time I heard that the
algorithm can tell if you're gay before
you know oh boy and I was like I'm
screwed it's terrifying on the internet
yeah yeah why because just by what you
look at how long you hold how long you
stare at Mateo or whatever you know what
it is if that's the case kind of
explains the videos
there's such a thing as an admiration
stare doesn't mean you're gay of course
[Laughter]
all right
I appreciate a dick in the ass yeah I
like it that's all the prostate is I'm
in I had that done you guys too young
for that go again yeah get it yeah I'm a
good looking Doctor too hang on there
for a little while make yourself
comfortable
what's the procedure like
two in there yeah two I think it was two
two doctors
one was filming what are you gonna do
so wait you got the milking I got it did
you did it feel great because they
always say it's the best thing ever I
mean I must be free I didn't get milked
you just got tested oh I didn't get milk
that's what I'm asking no yeah just go
and see if it's swollen or anything it's
like a rub and Tuck I don't think that's
what doctors do
his name could be Doc I figure is that
the barber why not
no I get my prostate check because I'm
40 I was 46. you're 40 what 40. I just
turned 47 last week
it does die early
but I'm gonna look good that's right
your skin looks good yes all right are
you still smoking no I just quit that's
so crazy you asked that yeah yeah we
went to I saw you with like a marble red
I was like that's nice it's not a good
one do it it's not a good I saw another
fat guy smoking and I was like man is
that what I look like it's nice he has
like body dysmorphia where like most
people think they're fat yeah he thinks
he's like 215. we'll be driving down the
street and he'll see a guy who's like
significantly less fat I always I'm not
as fat as that guy am I am like you
could eat that guy for lunch you're like
that chair was already broken
yeah I quit three weeks ago I'm on the
zens so you're over the hump with this
yeah because you're not you're not
craving it like a son of a [__] I am
but I just take the little I take the
little nicotine pouches those are big
now people yeah they're all right yeah
yeah they're all right Zen Latin
pickleball
oh yeah that's a very coupling thing to
do too very couply and I was like ah
this sounds like a nightmare and we had
a we had the best time who won uh well
we me and my lady beat them and then we
wrote you Sarah and then I went there
and then they'd be a couple of swingers
yeah
Wife Swap what do you play uh we went to
Long Island City and uh it ain't cheap
by the way real because I can't believe
they got you out to Long Island City it
wasn't easy and it's snowy and gay and
you know I'm hungover so it was tough
but we got there and I'm glad I did I
sweat it all out now Joan Sarah they're
they're your close friends has there
been situations where you've done couple
things or you didn't know the boyfriend
or didn't know the girlfriend or it was
like one of those things nah I refuse to
do that dude I refuse it's a nightmare
I've almost gotten drugged to a couple
of office parties like oh they want to
meet you get the [__] out of them
those two shouldn't mix office and party
no that's a night I don't want to do
meet and greet with my fans yeah yeah
right
no I do but I also like office party
it's like that's where I'm like [__]
that sounds rough I mean that's straight
to the bar I love my girl's family all
that kind of stuff I just can you do it
sober
yeah I do their family sober yeah we
were just there she's from Hawaii we
were just in Hawaii with them for for
nine days Hawaii
put them on the streets at Detroit yeah
yeah but my lady I'm lucky her family
they just 11 A.M
you know that's all my family knows and
my wife comes over and she's like do you
guys just always just drink yeah at
every function I go yeah what's the
drink of choice at our house uh it's
just usually beer beer women drink wine
dudes drink beer or we'll do like
Manhattans but that'll be like let's do
Manhattans tonight I'll get the stuff
Manhattans are probably my favorite
cocktail soup baby I got turned on
um maybe like five years ago or four
years ago to the martini the vodka dirty
martini that's my number one I knocked
them back I love it it's like drinking
olive juice exactly [__] you up and you
have nine of them feel good nothing
hotter than a woman drinking a martini
yeah
all right he got me I was going for
cocktails
maybe when she's kissing another girl
that's the hottest what are we drinking
here Patty we uh so I got the garbage
cocktail first it's uh what's called the
duggarita I wait I know these guys are
fans of Red Lobster so who ain't you
know what I mean Cheddar Bay Biscuits
also yeah oh [__] oh really
thanks buddy
I'm okay he's on two packs a day cheddar
cheddar biscuits though
I'll do one yeah
right
we gotta do a poll for the folks at home
on Twitter Who's hotter beard you or
Patty the Baddie oh man these are Vans
did you make the are these from there
you got these just for us
we should go to Red Lobster after that
yeah
he's your top shelf oh yeah so wait this
is a you said Mountain Dew Margarita
Mountain Dew margarita
I love it Mountain Dew is a pretty good
they came out with their uh it's a
pretty damn good soda yeah I don't drink
it anymore but holy [__] code Red's no
joke that's oh it's great that's when
you've really reached white trash
Oh you know it's white trash pie is the
White Rock Star can oh my God the
monster that's it anything white like
that yeah trash my check is cleared with
uh My Monster Energy partnership so yes
I agree
it's just games you got monster money I
got they were on my tour yeah they do
that right it was a lot of like they're
like can you can you drink it in front
of us and I was just like I just I'll do
this yeah I'm a coffee drinker I drink
it in front of they want you to do it in
the camera [__] yeah or if you're not a
cop
hahaha
what's these guys wearing a while
to be five days later I'm like [__] yeah
I went in too deep they just came out
with their uh well like their Seltzer or
whatever right really I haven't had it
yeah oh everybody's doing that pull it
up and I thought one of wasn't what's
his name supposed to be the spokesman of
that who wasn't Bert
uh that feels about right I thought so I
remember him talking about it that would
make sense damn because he had it Earl
we were on his bus and he had it well it
should go straight to Charlie Sheen for
that dude that looks aggressive holy
[__]
exploding dude how about him losing
really yeah he lost
like no he got he got beat up pretty
good uh it wasn't close isn't that guy
in love island or something too he was
no he was on Big Brother I think or
whatever they're he's a boxer though
right yeah he was a boxer they both
kicked my ass I know that yeah yeah his
brother's Tyson Fury yeah yeah which is
why he wanted to do it was why Jake Paul
wanted to do it to be like Tyson Fury
the big Irish the big British guy yeah
no [__] yeah the Gypsy King Gypsy King
that's it he's like the Charlie Murphy
yeah so he yeah but still the Charlie
Murphy was all right yeah it was all
right so funny oh [__] yeah the color of
that drink is all right what's on the
rim oh they're gonna say Doritos
now you're thinking that looks like
Colorado vomit right there that's what
that looks like oh this is Flint water
[Laughter]
did you guys just get tuned up to win
this show I would assume like after yeah
especially if you're piggybacking
episodes and you're gonna pick it up for
the shows later you gotta just yeah yeah
when we came in I felt like I got to a
party late and you guys you guys are
already kind of getting after uh-huh you
gotta adjust yourself a little bit we
did the clean comic first
no but this is yeah this definitely
takes a toll on some late night I've
definitely showed up to the seller where
they're like are you drunk I remember I
saw you a couple weeks ago there and
you're like I've been drinking Scotch
all day
it's doing a podcast get out of here
yeah it feels like my YouTube Hollywood
Story yeah
there's two bags you drink but you're
working we're working we're working this
is a job
[Laughter]
your mom's like I need you to drink
three Mountain Dew Margaritas it's
better than that better than we might be
doing push-ups
think about how much better we'd look I
know we might be doing push-ups that's
potato spot
we might be doing crunches yeah we and
Mateo and we almost drank Muscle Milk uh
Margaritas oh yeah that would have been
fun would have been fun we did a live
stream and we found a drink over a
Brooklyn comedy club uh that had Yoo-hoo
in it the uh no uh clue you no what the
[__] was it clue Yahoo or something like
that vodka Kahlua and Yoo-hoo and it was
it was fantastic can't go wrong with you
it was so good you put period blood in
it it was so good and we do
[Laughter]
thank you
all right
can I have The Coop glass absolutely I
love it
thank you I gotta say I prefer martini
glass really now especially you know a
big martini glass where it's not shaken
out yeah
but it's very trashy that you guys
didn't have enough glasses yeah
cheers fellas cheers thank you fellas to
the Irish
one of my favorite jokes about St
Patrick's Day that's all right that's
goddamn delicious that is phenomenal
[__] have you heard have you heard uh
Jon Stewart's bit about the St Patrick's
Day Parade how they wouldn't let gays uh
marched in the parade and he goes
because we won't want anything to mess
with the Dignity of that parade when
you're pissing behind a dumpster you
don't want some homo checking you out
come on by the way Jon Stewart man who's
looking good I never really got into
it his stand-up was solid he had the
great bit I mean it's probably a
signature bit about uh Jews he's like
Jews complain but black people had the
genius to make it into the blues you
know and here's the whole thing about it
that's a great it's a great premise
that's fun you guys do Saint Patty's Day
I do it all I mean I do Cinco de Mayo
I'm not Mexican I do Saint Patty's Day
I'm not Irish I do uh Hanukkah I'm not a
Jew you get after and get into it yeah
it was always it was always a solemn day
at our house it was very Catholic really
really yeah but we went to go to church
and then we'd have corned beef and
cabbage in the soda bread that was my
favorite wow ours was like black out go
to like Finnegan's weight down in
Fishtown or whatever and just get
[__] black go there for like Kegs and
Eggs or whatever and Kegs and Eggs yeah
just really get after it damn what's
that Kegs and Eggs beer and breakfast
for the most part oh damn yeah it would
be like a breakfast buffet like you're
at like a [__] Courtyard Marriott
starting the day with beer or something
I can't really I need to start with like
a bloody mary if I'm drinking early 100
I can move on a beer after but I need
the breakfasty vibe if you're flying on
vacation what's your move at the at the
at the lounge or at the hotel bar I
never take vacations but uh if I were to
take one probably like a probably like a
whiskey drink I would probably do like a
Manhattan early beer and stuff I love it
yeah I was just in Puerto Rico beers in
the morning every single day exactly
crack a Corona or whatever I guess
Corona oh it's a little lighter it's a
little lighter it is wobbles you know
true I do I'm a it's cliche but I'm
hungover at the airport lounge I get the
BM I get the Bloody Mary yeah dude we
went to Florida what two weeks or three
weeks ago yeah he drank 15 Bloody Mary's
in the airport you did until they'll
just keep until the time we got until we
landed he had drink 15 Bloody Mary
that's the most Tomatoes you've ever had
I don't know
yeah
really drunk yeah and he's like you're
not drinking I'm like I'm the one who's
got to go get a rental car after this I
can't waddle up to Avis and be like oh
that literally I do the same thing I
told my toy manager like man I wasn't
really that drunk in Atlantic City goes
you picked a fight with a stranger at
the card table yeah hey that was my age
I think I did 20 on the way there on the
way to Hawaii it's crazy wait 20 Bloody
Mary's on the plane you don't have the
nine out of the earth to switch it up
but all that tomato juice would make me
feel weird I don't know I like it I like
them I put my movies on it's not
watching it that's what you're worried
about is it yeah
20 cocktails that's a lot of sodium who
are you my aunt he also had 19
sandwiches that's way too much cayenne
pepper
are you kidding me those little onions
you can have 15 drinks on a flight
that's pretty [__] impressive nine
hours no nine hours no well the fifth to
the 15 was you had maybe six at the bar
at the airport okay you did about nine
on the flight to Orlando it's like two
two or two hours fourth flight you need
to get drunk on because of those shitty
little kids so much screaming on an
Orlando flight Mickey Mouse ears yeah we
didn't have it too bad well and we did
we did Disney we did it right man but
that boarding process it's either the
elderly or kids it's a slow board yeah
yeah you hit Disney yeah
because he had never been so like one of
the patreon goals is like I'll take you
to Disney never been to Disney
was a kid I'm sure you went I went once
yeah what about you no yeah my parents
actually no we didn't we didn't actually
we went to we did Universal Studios okay
that's the Trashy we went to it is it
really yeah what of course I don't know
you're that close to Disney you don't go
yeah it's like this you poop on planes
no I can't fit
so yeah he's very open yeah he could
have just said no and stop it it's a
whole process these days he's a lot on a
plane he's a lot to be around on a plane
he really believed it
comedy show they don't give you
Hawaiian Airlines
sir you've had enough
doesn't your tummy hurt sir
it is embarrassing to get cut off with
drinks too though on a flight yeah I've
never been cut off but I've seen the
person get cut off and I'm like that's
[__] humiliated have you been to the
AmEx Lounge in JFK no no get in there
that's great there's a proper Speakeasy
you walk in and you go let me get I
gotta I was I just did it to Puerto Rico
I was like Manhattan it was like 9 A.M
or whatever it was just like you feel
like you got to do it I'm on vacation
it's beautiful yeah MX yeah I have an
Amex so listen when you go through JFK
you're not doing all that stuff I got
the Delta Lounge I got the United Lounge
is that enough yeah let me see yeah
that'll get you in Mr Nigerian Tyrion
that sounds high-end no that is it's
everything's free the feeder gets in
there you're fine I think it's I think
it's like uh yeah you should be able to
do it but if not I think it's like 400
bucks a year but you get a bunch of
stuff you get like 50 Uber credit they
give you the money back you're flying up
front right every now and then what
you're an idiot I know dude
he's not
wait no theoretically I can fit in the
seat and all that stuff it's
uncomfortable for the person next to it
it's gonna be uncomfortable for you
though too it's very yeah the flight
that's why I'm drinking [__] 15
Bloody Marys destroy I'm watching the
Kurt Warner story
that's why you're uncomfortable now when
we when we travel for for the show we
you know we sit up front just because we
do usually same day get up the next
morning and fly out to the same day I
can't go so we want to be fresh I can't
I'll do it just on even on vacate I just
can't that's too nice yeah but I can't
it's that much better it's not so bad
with money that I don't care I'm like
whatever especially the crow I just did
Spokane and back coach
why I didn't understand I did South
America or South Africa coach and China
think about how much are you doing coach
defeater gigs huh how much money do you
make in Spokane in your [__] leave
don't say but a lot and you're you're in
the air because when you land you land
you're done no I hear that I did do
coach coming back uh going to Utah but I
usually go the Utah's five hours yeah no
I [__] up that's a sneaky I landed and
I was like I'm [__] dumb you do it
because you don't want to spend the
money you know you you're trying to be
frugal seat to seat
there's also very responsible we're you
know he's a regular sized guy you're
tall yeah true you can watch it I'm
bigger and that's the other thing that's
true you don't want to be too Frugal or
you can't enjoy your life free drinks up
there yeah that's nice If you flew to
South Africa and Coach with a lady that
I guess because those end up taking
those cost like 25 000. that's crazy and
I want to see if she really likes me
yeah
sitting back in the bulkhead the worst
is I got a gig in London and they flew
me first class and she's like I want to
go to London and I you know I want to be
the good hubby so I bought her ticket
but
23d
I respect I brought her some snacks
I really did I went back there and gave
her like my cupcakes I'll see it these
are from the cheap guy up front yeah
that was hilarious both TSA pre-check
and all that stuff nah clear okay
this is really they're they're so good
at interviewing they switch into their
podcast
they're very good at this yeah you're
killing it
you should I just go we're not I'm not
taking my shoes off wow that's a great
way to divorce yeah it's right here she
she made it she tries to beat me which
she never does yeah all right you have
fun with your game I'll be cheating
but yeah that's pretty good it helps uh
but clear has gotten me a few saved
flights like if I didn't have clear I
would have missed it because you jump us
which I don't like that bothers me yeah
jump you yeah they walk in and they go
oh this guy's clear and they cut in
front of the TSA pre-check just get it
you got clear I got it all yeah
yeah
we're flying every week
it is hilarious that we are wiped out
from this like it's like a painful like
oh my God I had the hardest day I got
drunk with my friends it wears on you
oh holy [__] I'm sorry can we get him 14
more of those please the rim is unreal
yeah it's great rim job good this is
fantastic yeah it was delicious I'm
sorry
we got a full boy I tend to suck them
down
yeah sure I'll do one of those as well
I got spots tonight but it's lime juice
uh Jameson this time
I'm not a Moscow Mule yeah but yeah we
don't call them that anymore bro Ukraine
mule there we go you have kicker a
little respect
no I love uh I love a uh a good mule man
Kentucky mule I don't think I've ever
had one I don't think I've ever had one
what kind of meal are we having I got
offered to be a mule one what's an Irish
rugs yeah yeah really yeah where to
where uh it wasn't anything I didn't put
anything in like Columbia no that I
would have done you took off with the
goods maybe that show Locked Up Abroad
oh I love it there's always some cocky
guy like I got this you know tape
anything to me I'll be fine you know
what scared me from that was um the
Joaquin Phoenix Vince Vaughn movie with
him in Paradise that was that was like
the modern day uh [__] that Midnight
Cowboy yeah yeah or Midnight Express
yeah and it was broke down palace which
was similar which is a true story yeah
with Claire Danes I don't remember that
can't do that in first class
although I took all over them you asked
me if I if I [__] on a plane I don't but
I fart all the time oh you got to I see
if I can get it because first of all
that shit's loud as hell yeah and
everyone zoned out and they had their
headphones on if I if I I'll do a test
market I'll do a little sneaker and see
if it smells there's a guy who sits next
to you every flight we notice
if it doesn't smell man I'm full
automatic I'm like a [__] AR-15 up
there
oh I do that
well the airplane farts I know I
think that's the classier thing to do
because if you just fart next to your
neighbor that that's it's a sneak attack
it's horrible this yeah that's that's
first what are the line smell like that
yeah wow
I didn't catch that at all what is that
what you're saying your farts smell oh
you caught it
yeah that might just be me don't get too
close it smells like cheese the whole
thing his body I don't mean that's my
deodorant man you got a Velveeta right
here like a Kraft mac and cheese it's my
first mule right here there we go here
we go look at that cup man that's
beautiful the copper cup makes it
The Mensch Off the Bench hell yeah love
it filling in for beer juice whoa this
is [__] you want to take a sip of
this
[__] all right that's whiskey
nice
that's good Jameson is one of the best
whiskeys I love it wait that's jmo and
uh club soda and that is that is a
phenomenal drink beer pops you guys
don't have chronovirus nah
oh that's all right that's a lie but you
said it was a lot of confidence I like
it how about the person whenever you're
sick they're like whiskey helps oh yeah
sweat it out I understand maybe like one
glass but the person who's like who's
like drink a few hot toddies I'm like
dude that's you think alcohol is going
to cure my [__] my sinus infection
yeah cured everything sorry when I was
doing blow back in the day I uh that
used to take away a fever if I had a
fever really yeah because it burned I
don't know yeah I just went away like
horseradish it just burns up the nose
yeah a little Wasabi damn
mm-hmm yeah I mean back in the day Don
Draper had a bad day he would drink he
had a tough project he would drink he
hated his wife you know he had a
headache it was all booze whenever they
get anything done like the peaky
blinders they would have been staggering
around the city breaking all that
[__] Scotch well back in the day they
didn't even drink water because it was
crazy
booze crazy that's like when someone
says I'm real thirsty and they asked her
yeah [__] nuts that's why how did you
feel like the hydration thing is like a
little overrated
I understand drinking water is important
but the people who you see with The Jug
like this I'm like settle down yeah it's
a little much the gallon jug look I'll
drink a lot of water if I'm like
sweating if I'm like running or
something but I'm you know sure just the
all-day water I drink too much coffee
yeah I can't if I just if I drink that
much water and coffee and booze I won't
I'll never stop pissing yeah sometime
today sorry that's your sneeze that's a
problem that was the least intimidating
sneeze I've ever heard yeah put it on
dates that's like an alien yeah yeah
it's a problem
move it on
oh man hot button issues over here yeah
right thank you brother appreciate it
man sounds good segue
what which one
Mark sneeze what too much water yeah the
water thing and look I understand that
water is essential I'm not saying like
don't drink water I'm just saying The
Jug people do get on my nerves and I
hate The Jug
yeah they got to bring their own tin
thing they got to bring their own bottle
it's like where are you going that water
isn't readily available right especially
you get a bottle of water on every
corner not to go back to the airport but
those reusable water stations at the
airport
put it in the old coat and then I
refilled the airport really well I'm
always hung over on flights so I'm like
I need that water how's that water hello
guys it's fine it's like a water
fountain Mark remember we did a gig Mark
and I did a gig opening for Amy Schumer
in Orlando years ago and uh and Rachel
was on the show yeah and I remember we
got so [__] up Mark and I we were just
yeah we're in Amy's hotel room it's like
a massive massive Suite we're watching
the NBA Playoffs more than a flip up
game with the phone what is remember
that heads up heads up yeah we were just
right Downing whiskey Downing ripped and
I remember I'm puking in the in the
airport uh bathroom the next morning and
all I remember I look up and I just see
a little hand over the stall ginger ale
Mark hooking up ginger ale yeah good
buddy
yes they have they're out of manishevits
got you some Google
what is it what Kramer's makeup
you like arugula yeah you're Skin and
Bones yeah I got brisket at Newman's
well remember
the uh the the 20s you would do I'll
take a Chardonnay I'll have a beer I'll
have a whiskey I'll have a vodka soda
I'll have a shot of gin a shot of Jaeger
like you didn't do any of that
yeah I'll start off with a couple of
martinis and then I'll have uh if we're
getting like oysters or something like
that to kick things off I'll do like a
sauvignon blanc if we're having a steak
I'll do a red wine and then he'll
probably start getting an IPA at some
point that'll look good I'll have one of
those and finish it off probably in
espresso Martini damn this might just be
an intervention for you yeah right
what's going on in that gut yeah
that story started cool and ended with
like are you okay yeah yeah holy [__] oh
the espresso Martini at the end my God
man that was a real bait and switch with
the oysters uh starter yeah a few drinks
later I'm puking in the [__] bathroom
yeah what's your Yak rate nothing yeah
wow he's like a great white he just you
know cut him open there's like a license
plate a boot
up uh
if I ate a lot the night before when I
brush my teeth I have to like gag myself
for some reason
when I when I brush my tongue I don't
feel like my teeth are clean unless I
gag a little bit I know what you mean am
I the only one that doesn't oh yeah
you're one of those people no I just use
my toothbrush but if I don't if I don't
go back far enough where I where I have
to gag I feel like I didn't get it clean
enough wish my ex was like that
I know the feeling because if I don't
get my my gums hurting I feel like I
didn't really get a good brush yeah but
I got the other gag it's similar that'll
make me puke a little bit sometimes but
other than that nothing yeah all right
we're learning a lot here right do we do
Electro toothbrush or regular regular I
have an electric I just don't like it
same I go I go regularly yeah right I
like Dylan or I don't go electric I
always forget to charge it or whatever
or the heads and then I just take it you
put it right over your sink yeah no they
get so gross too yes the [__] bottom
of that smells like [__] ass yeah I
can't stand it I'm with you I like the
regular yeah old school old school
analog hey Amish and I floss every day
I can't imagine what you're pulling out
of that junk
[Music]
do you do the pick or do you do the
string I do the string damn you're all
old school yeah it's like magnet fishing
I pull on Old bikes and [__] like that
some gun that was using a murderer yeah
the priest yeah like the Glides or
whatever the fuzzy one that just [__]
I love the bug get more in fuzz is good
more pops out it's very it's very
exciting when you get a little piece of
it yeah
they say that's more important than
brushing your teeth no is that right
yeah remember that Hedberg joke they say
it's hard to quit smoking you know it's
harder to start flossing that's true I
always say I'm gonna flaws and I never
do it yeah I got to get back I'm always
like if I'm sober I do it but if I'm
drunk at all I'm like what am I gonna
floss it's crazy you're just too you're
lazy yeah I'm more likely not to brush
my teeth at night same yeah and you wake
up and you're like damn you gotta do it
something died in there it tastes like
yeah morning booze breath you know you
just snoring all night the dust mouth's
all dry and [__]
you got a brush you ever have someone
that's not everybody but when like
garlic hits them a different way yes and
like they really smell like garlic like
I've worked with a couple people it's
like what the f have you ever brushed
your teeth I know it just sucked for
someone who's like really bad breath
because we all know that I remember we
did a roast with it oh I don't want to
say his name but classic every joke was
about it was like dude did someone [__]
in your [__] mouth like every joke
yeah and he was just like he had no I
had no idea I didn't know I heard that
did you guys see I would be so mad I
would always want somebody to tell me of
course something in your teeth if I have
a booger if I have bad breath I would
want somebody to tell me of course but
it was it was hilarious that like it's
not like we coordinated this attack no
we're like What should we write it for
about a roaster oh yeah it feels like
someone's [__] in his mouth yeah
everyone wait you guys were writing
jokes for him no he was on the Deus
uh-huh and every joke from every other
comic was about his halitosis oh and he
didn't know he had it so he was like
whoa it was like an intervention
he's killed himself that was Ralphie May
I better I bet he started tongue
scraping that's a bad breath I think he
got a tongue scrape it could be a tooth
in the back too a dead tooth or
something cooking in there this could be
something instead of interventions we
should roast and then have everybody say
that thing and then maybe he'll change
you fart too much
ah [__] mark it makes all of us
uncomfortable supposed to be a joke you
got to do a joke with it you can just
tell me that's an intervention that is
just an intervention which is all sad
mark you farted at my mom's funeral
I had beans
we now put her to rest hold on a minute
do me a favor though if I die open
casket get a fart machine in there every
time somebody goes oh we had a good time
just randomly do it yeah yeah dude in a
funny funeral remember to take a bunch
of different supplements can be a pain
ag1 by athletic greens makes it simple
just scoop shake and have alongside your
breakfast that's it I take this [__] all
the time don't you I love it every day I
do it every day for breakfast good stuff
uh yeah I before I even eat I shake it
up I put in my
vodka soda packed with over 75 vitamins
and minerals for a major boost to your
gut mood energy and even skin hair and
nails ag-1 gives you increased energy
and mood support making it easy to live
your best life it takes under a minute
making athletic greens the simplest way
to start a new healthy habit if you're
looking for an easier way to take
supplements athletic greens is giving
you a free one-year supply of vitamin D
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase go to athleticgreens.com
drunk that's athleticgreens.com drunk
hey now there should be more funny
funerals yeah would you want an open
casket
I don't know no I don't think so I would
want one go ahead really why not let me
creep you out one last time yeah I was
gonna say you don't work that good now
maybe you got a full wig on Elvis wig
chop maybe a little bit of makeup I'll
pull it together in the bottom of the
night yeah but you gotta you gotta have
a guy dress you down and put chemicals
on you I don't know that's too much now
cremated that's the way I'm with you
yeah 100 there's a video of the guy that
recorded um
sounds of him going let me out
oh now that's a fun guy you put it in
like underneath his casket and all his
friends are laughing but if you didn't
know him he'd probably freak you out
there was that one not too long ago at a
club somewhere uh this guy died and he's
like 20 something or whatever and they
just said hey we're having like a
memorial for him at this bar at this
club and they were like okay and they
snuck them in snuck the body in and like
propped him up and like he had like
sunglasses everybody's taking pictures
of them and [__] yeah I came here he
came he can't have a dead body in our
bar and they were like all right what do
you mean I love that it was hilarious
that was South America though remember
that [__] which one oh on The Wire
whenever
I would love that at like patties just
be there it's just everybody I know I'm
propped up on a table my dad telling me
he remembers when he was a kid because
they were real Irish when he was a kid
he's like I remember that they would
have them like on ice like on a pool
table and they would have them there for
like a couple of days and they'd be
drinking yeah because you start [__]
that's awesome with the coins on top
next to the oysters you ordered that
[Laughter]
fine but I was going to say in South
America the the kids they get like uh
like like embalmed and like mummied and
they put them in positions there's one
where they keep them in the house and
the kids like sit and cross like it he's
sitting just like you are now pull it up
wearing like a track suit I don't know
how you would Google that
that's like that body's exhibit remember
that oh I don't want to do it I didn't
do it holy [__] you ever been to the
mother Museum that I ever showing yeah I
love it a little pricey but uh it cost
you an arm and a leg
[Music]
I loved it I loved it well what's this
is that a dead guy
you don't want to whiff on that one
all right all right all right he whipped
yeah yeah that's crazy
that would [__] freak me the [__] out
that's why that's pretty cool there
that's fun they should add a dead
Kardashian blowing it
the only one I can think of is the
father
yeah okay yeah this [__] drink is
yeah
you might got something here you have a
bunch of them I don't like to get drunk
on sugary drinks like it's the sugary it
overtakes the buzz of the booze I might
hang over the next day with the off the
sugars
we did a Kool-Aid Kool-Aid vodka tonics
it'd be weird if you did it with another
comment yeah the lane boozler
Blues but yeah she uh or he he he put
them back but like I was you know when
you're hungover like uh I'm hurt but
that was like pain I didn't be a Judd on
the next day oh and we did a sober up
which we don't normally do I think we
did like kombucha we were just like
we'll do a sober we had to we didn't
want to keep going we felt like [__]
what do you do if someone doesn't drink
oh he would not drink with them yeah
yeah coffee I mean we've also got we've
also drank when they didn't but you know
yeah we've had list on a tail right
right right yeah we did milkshakes yeah
there you go that's fun still did
stogies yeah there you go but we don't
we don't do yeah we don't need I mean we
have Norton coming on he doesn't drink
that's true we got a trans woman
get somebody you can blow yeah let's go
by the way he was on trans for anybody
oh yeah he's been pro-trans since the
80s good to know no uh no love for that
head of the curve yeah and hookers
trendsetter trendsetter
his new [__] is great it's great his new
[__] Jim Norton's new stuff is really
he's one of the funniest we had him on
and it was like oh really the first time
I met him yeah it was the first time we
met him he just came in like somebody
else had set it up and he was making
jokes so quick he's so the point where I
stopped being the whole like at the
co-host of the show I literally said on
the mic I went he's so quick like I was
just like what like watching us in all
why doesn't he do more paw like I don't
see him around he should be he's so
perfect for it they do a lot of radio
man 30 hours of radio yeah he's [__]
he's done it forever you're right if he
made the rounds like he's so good at it
and I think of the guys who are that
quick on radio of like all time and it's
like Norden and Artie Lange
the two maybe the two quickest knives
yeah that was for me it was really quick
too listening to Howard was when right
when already came on because I got a job
as a driver and I would just listen to
it all day wow when fighting him when
Norm would come on oh
got a real big mouth can we also talk
about gambling away our money at casinos
like Norm was the [__] King animal he
was like all of his money and be like ah
started fresh you know I'm back I'm
there's that story and he walked he had
like 40 Grand yeah briefcase I don't
know if it's true or just like a lore he
had like 40 or 60 Grand in a briefcase
in Atlantic City I think maybe just
walked out to appear and throw it in the
water yeah because he was like I'm Gonna
Lose It Anyway let's just [__] get it
over what yeah and he goes I feel the
same as if I would like okay I got a
better idea maybe a charity of some sort
of St Jude's Children's Hospital we have
a little dinner yeah right yeah yikes
that is not that is a problem right
there yeah man that's rolling the
[__] dice literally although I did
find a lot of chips in my jacket when I
got back from AC and that's a bad
feeling too oh really [__] now I gotta I
gotta go back to yeah I gotta go back
and bring down the house you should try
giving that to a hobo you know like here
just start walking take these that's the
way you know if you know you know
somebody's a real heroin addict if you
give them [__] chips
and they get down there wait you were a
driver what are we talking limo no I
drove uh I was telling you before with
the fake titties this guy used to
um sell fake boobs his wife worked for
this laser company it was right when
laser hair removal started to get
popular so they teamed up together and
started a laser hair removal rental
business because he had the ends with
all the high end plastic surgeons out in
Long Island Westchester here in the city
and I would drive the equipment and
technician around oh okay wow yeah so
this was like lasering off hair on
people yeah yeah like people just have
hairy vaginas before that oh yeah I
think so yeah wow but this is like face
all this kind of stuff it was a tough
time man it was a rough time but it was
awesome I just got like a 20 breakfast
from Burger King and I'd say in the
truck all day Sleep listen to [__]
Stern that's the best yeah I used to
move furniture and we'd have to drive
the truck and drive in the truck you
still got paid yeah you got a gig in uh
Cherry Hill New Jersey you're like [__]
yes because you get paid for all that
ride 100 yeah those were good days
nothing like sleeping in a car sorry
falling asleep on the Subway or
something well he's the king of falling
asleep on the subway
really yeah Reggie Rose could do that a
lot Reggie Conquest oh really we'd see
him the next day be like man like what
he's like I don't get home till like
eight o'clock in the morning I'm like
why he's like I woke up out in Rockaway
yeah that happened to me where I like I
woke up I'd missed because I live in the
Washington Heights and I would yes I get
up to the end and be like all right I
have a few more stops and I would pass
out sit there go all the way out to the
rockaways wake up out there yeah [__]
fall back asleep wake up and just like
all night but that sleep is unquested
that sleep is almost better than no but
I think it's better than sleeping at
home
like 40
it reminds me of falling asleep in the
backseat of the car like my uncle was
driving her falling asleep in like
seventh period in high school
here's where some of that's negated when
you wake up like oh yeah yeah
that's part of the rush you wake up in
like the park or some [__] I've done
that a couple times and you just wake up
and you're just like what have I done
the craziest book I'm in the Park yeah
it's got blood all over his face
well when you're a kid you're just
getting drunk yeah you pass out the
craziest that's right you're a shitty
kid Eric Bergstrom you've heard this
story he woke up on the AirTran whoa he
fell asleep on the subway
sleepy stupor he got on the air Trail
which means you had to swap buy a ticket
he had got the same train he got on he
was like JFK terminal a what the [__]
legendary would have been though if he
got in a flight just anywhere yeah he's
like Cincinnati
well that was at skank fast Crystal you
know Crystal yeah
hey dude he shout out to him was doing
mushrooms or at or something and was
like allegedly no he's pretty public
about it uh and it was like three in the
morning and he's like I gotta see the
mountains man oh no got on a flight and
like came to in Aspen shut up I swear to
God it was like I don't know I just had
this urgency the mountains and he came
to and he's like what the [__] am I
doing here Meanwhile we're in Vegas
there's mountains all around us yeah
yeah right yeah that is one of the
craziest things I've ever heard holy I
did it once I did it once and I mean you
know the joke because you were there
when I wrote it but it's I we were
leaving Michael J's house once Mark at
like 7 A.M oh yeah we were both wrecked
and I remember walking maybe it was 6
a.m I don't know we walk out and I Mark
and I stumbled out we go our separate
ways and a cab walks up to me and he
goes he just sees me stumbling and he's
trying to rip me off and he goes uh he
goes JFK and I was oh no he goes
LaGuardia is what he said LaGuardia and
I said yeah yeah all right I just get in
the car I was [__] up
and it and true story I [__] sober up
in the joke I say I come to and like you
know 20 minutes later I was like whoa
JFK that's right
in reality I was like it took but it
took me like 20 minutes to realize and
we had to turn back I was like no no
wait wow I was we were bombed that was
the night when Michael J was pouring us
uh like Johnny Walker Blue and I was
like you were wasting this on two
shit-faced yeah who don't know the
difference right yeah good point I uh I
got all banged up at patties one night
it's one of those things where they like
shut the door and yeah cool summer night
and it's like now like 6 15 a.m or
whatever stumble out the sun's coming up
and I just was like so drunk and just
like man I love [__] comedy this was
great this is so cool I gotta I get in a
car and I live up by the hype by the gwb
and I was like I get out to get a
Gatorade I'm like you know what I've
never walked across the gwb I'll do that
hey it's like 6 30 in the morning sun's
coming up I don't realize they haven't
they used I don't know if he's still
there they used to have a guy sit on the
gwb to talk you down from jumping there
wasn't good there wasn't a a net there
that's a girl a couple years ago how do
you get that gig so I'm up there dude
I'm like my neck somebody like all or
something I looked like I just got hit
by a bus and he's like how you doing man
I'm like just loving life right now but
like really liking she left you huh big
guy and he was like take the kids on you
he was like don't do it man or something
he's like it's not work are you good and
I'm like yeah and then it all hit I'm
like oh [__] I'm like I just came to
watch the sunrise dude or whatever but
he was tall he was like slowly creeping
up to me wow would it be great if they
put like on the other side it's like a
Jeff Ross guy like you look like [__]
you should jump you got halitosis yeah
like a roaster pick what side you want I
remember you know Steve fabricam from
The Cellar sure outdoor Steve so he told
me a story once so he was he walked on
the bridge with a girl late at night and
she's a killer
this gang he's like kind of Gang season
there and they're kind of [__] with
him and it's one of the things where
he's like they're gonna [__] me up and
they hand him a drink like take a sip of
this and he knows like if he takes a sip
they're just gonna [__] beat him up
and eat for whatever reason he just goes
I just quit the stuff and they were like
all right and they let him he's like I
think that saved my [__] life wow so
weird it must have been the Van Buren
boys
I don't mess with their own it's still
holding the pepper dude science I've
been re-washing because it's on Netflix
and like the significant shrinkage
episode
holy [__] one of my favorite lines of
that is she's got a great body buddy
that's the same actress that was in
Boogie Nights and also in uh
right uh she played the she she married
Don Cheadle
it up she was also in Magnolia as the
daughter of Jimmy Gator her body damn I
love whatever no difference
we've talked about this before but
you're such a film nerd yeah we love it
her body in Seinfeld was absolutely
made her up to be old to play somebody
yeah my favorite line in that uh that
episode is when George won't stop kind
of zinging this woman and and uh Jerry
goes easy big fella
their table yeah yeah it's really quite
breathtaking but you know that's a guy
is so good he's great I'm such a
Seinfeld psycho about the show that I uh
I watched the the DVD box set blah blah
blah behind the scenes [__] and Larry
David kept running onto the screen and
going say shrinkage more just it's a
funny word just keep saying shrink
really and I love stuff like that it's
like calling when he keeps saying my
stuff yes your stuff and like you just
repeat a word it becomes funnier right
damn that's I mean so many of those old
Seinfeld episodes are just like it's
just non-stop that's crazy my girl
always tries to get me to watch
something new or you know like
everyone's talking about dude I watched
Seinfeld and Sopranos over and over yeah
yeah Sopranos is my number one rewatch I
have to stop around season five or like
the beginning of six I just get like
depressed yeah I'm like the end and it's
like no it's coming to the end but I
love all the Phil leotardo stuff but
it's just like oh his ending is one of
the finest the best yeah but it's a
great team uh I I do have a new wreck if
you haven't seen it the movie Megan dude
is it good
shout out to Tony Chang [__] kills
the killer man he's awesome he really
time he speaks I was laughing Wow have
you seen it yes it's he it's a good
movie right he was great in the 10 rings
too I haven't seen them
that's awesome Seinfeld wise I would
love to I do it with Donnelly and fiori
we just did it the other night uh yeah
who was the favorite who is the who do
you think the best one-off character is
oh he went off his work is tricky
because I do love the guy you know a guy
I love who's recurring is a guy who's
like you win in a thousand Cadillacs
that guy oh oh yeah he's on a few of
them
who feels great he's great just a
one-off one-off is tough the moil would
have to be up oh I think it's the Moyle
I know right
what are you gonna do yeah every line
out of the moyle's mouth is a [__]
punchline put it right on the edge and
it goes right into the shards
you know also it's great the guy that
ran the pizza place where the Frogger
was oh yeah
slip repeats all right yeah yeah yeah
he's not a friend of mine he already had
another one that I forget that it was
like it was a it was the Rival Bookman
but the librarian was pretty attractive
too I saw a thread some Sopranos like
dumb Sopranos threads where they're like
the amount of like Hitmen who have been
under Sopranos and it was just a Twitter
thread of all the random which is like
that Asian dude in Palm Beach
dudes we were like oh yeah that's yeah
that guy yeah it takes you to it's like
the way you hear a song it just takes
you to a [__] moment where you're
like yes you know who's great not the
heroin addict that hooked up the Italian
Hitman remember he could speak Italian
oh yeah yeah he's fantastic real seedy
looking dude yeah yeah which one was
this uh he's been in a he was in a cup
very nondescript yeah he was in he was
in a movie called dinner rush with Danny
Aiello I heard it's a great movie really
I love it my Grandpa loved that movie
dude old school [__] New York Indie
movies the clown John Favreau yeah yeah
that was his big shoe
yeah every time the DiMaggio boys
they're all blind and like beaten down
we don't work for drug dealers
they just they're all like in their late
70s they're like we can take care of
this week half of them can't see the 90s
did you guys watch Simpsons not huge but
not really yeah
show
have you guys seen this season of South
Park
yeah that made ways didn't say they try
to sew her they tried to sue them they
dropped it but yeah how humorous
I kind of like them at one point and
then I'm like oh yeah I like the fact
that they were leaving I'm like oh
that's pretty cool and I'm like this is
all just self-brandizing [__] pieces
but they left for the money right yeah
yeah they only got a 50 million dollar
Netflix deal a book deal everything that
book was like the best seller of all
time it's like broken all these records
it's crazy people like this [__] I don't
want to tell tails at a school I mean
they cut this but please I don't think
that's his kid oh he looks just like the
best friend that she was with yeah
princess dye was sleeping around you're
saying he looks exactly like the [__]
trainer did you ever see that that side
by side it's pretty crazy I mean I don't
want to get clipped by MI6 or anything
well they're out of the family so you're
good all right you have to go Syracuse
what happened
[Laughter]
you're a hell of a father
drunk
wait is that him well yeah who's that
guy yeah that would be his dad oh that's
it it was her like horse trainer or
something wow damn back on the saddle
again right that's it that's pretty dead
ringer right well that's true then he
made out like a bandit and that's
probably why he dipped him you know damn
oh interesting foil hat [__] and I'm
loving it yeah look at that yeah that's
pretty good the red hair too and he's so
much hotter than Charles yeah Charles is
a [__] horse yeah they really did him
a favor in the crown which I did like
that that's great crown was all right
the first two seasons were incredible oh
first two seasons were like
blew me the [__] away I don't like that
was Churchill oh my God Isn't it nice
for us to take one of their [__] jobs
yeah I appreciate it Trevor Noah John
Oliver James Corden no but it was uh
dude he would kill that episode where he
gets painted is one of the best episodes
of TV so good ever it's insane Gary
Oldman did a really good uh yeah he's
good Darkest Hour he's always good I
liked it yeah yeah old was all right he
kind of dodged uh cancellation they
tried to take him down old man what'd he
do I don't know but he there was a
moment where they were trying to take
him down from uh Ben Stiller pushed back
they're doing the Tropic Thunder after
all that every four years Tropic Thunder
Gets In The Heat again
the [__] the whole thing and then he
he pushed back I forgot about that too I
guess it was a lot but they went all in
the movie man he just doubled down like
last week on it right
what happens in the house stays in the
house you know what I mean exactly I
didn't know that Oldman huh how do you
like that alligator anti-semitic
language okay all right
oh well [__] is that bad that was 2018
he was yeah we're getting the benefit of
the doubt was he preparing for a roll
yeah it does say Daniel Day-Lewis okay
what did he say Denzel Washington
he's a good artist
who I mean both of them well old men
forget about it yeah played [__]
Drexel and uh
True Romance yeah yeah that was a weird
role dude
he's so good in that one doesn't he look
like a [__] pig in heat The Fifth
Element is really underrated that was
Gibson okay man we got to get Chris
Tucker on here dude
what'd they say what
Chris Tucker's coming on though holy
[__]
dude Money Talks is one of the funniest
[__] movies there was like only one
of the ones I had on VHS at a young age
and it was just like run that I will
snap crackle and pop your ass or
whatever he says Heather Locklear oh one
fine piece of Ace Sammy Davis Jr
she banged everybody too she had like
white snake and Motley Crew and skid row
and stayed Spade Sheen right machine for
a while he's got Bao Richie Sambora was
[__] he was like he was killing it yeah
he was with everybody
yeah a couple of times yeah yeah yeah
the cool the craziest one is uh what's
the Counting Crows guy the lead singer
Chris Robinson thank you he [__]
Phoebe Monica and Rachel really wild
friends is on the air so they have to go
to work and be like no way they went on
a rider
rock stars man yeah that was the first
concert I ever saw in New York at the
Beacon Theater they were great dude they
[__] but how do you pull three people
on the same cast that's like also at
their hottest I don't know the highest
hot also I would I didn't give Phoebe
the appreciation as a young kid now
looking back I'm like she was a [__]
she was hot yeah she's pretty and she's
a great comicator
yeah I think in the early years of
friends I heard that yeah Chris Robinson
[__] them up no I don't know no I was
on Conan with them
[Laughter]
I was yeah Romy Michelle oh yeah that's
a funny good stuff who's that her and
Christina Applegate who's here Sorvino
I'm not too shabby yikes Mighty
Aphrodite the best yeah Mira servino or
uh Marissa Tomei Tomei really okay sweet
spots Tomei is gonna if we're doing like
a bracket tournament
tomay's like a one seed yeah yeah what
are we doing dude my cousin Vinnie that
was insane I like hearing the wrestler
oh even better because she's also a
great actress but she's also brilliant
but then she's also that's right wow
that's right Bensonhurst she's beautiful
yeah she's great George her and uh my
cousin Vinnie I remember seeing that as
a kid and having like a little boner
dude I remember when she like
onesie that she wore oh pull it up when
she was on the streets up Mark Norman I
had a little boner
it was awkward though when they have
that like almost sex scene on the bed
because Joe Pesci is like so much like
an uncle or something like that but to
see him in that like you know sexy
position he's five one yeah
someone's that much older than their
love interests yeah like you ever
watched like it's a great movie you ever
watch like old school Sabrina with
Humphrey Bogart and obvious that's crazy
it's a great movie but it's still like
you're like he is he's 50 she's 15. yeah
it's nuts back then I'm listening
DiCaprio how about huh how about that
huh 19. yeah man he's he's walking up to
the line and he's looking at the line
yeah he's all right I respect it let him
do him it's legal is she who is she
European or American Jerusalem yeah
that's that's fine there you go they
don't care they're old souls yeah that's
true it's like the Iron Dome
but yeah what's fun about data 19 year
olds you get to show her stuff like
here's Seinfeld here's Seinfeld here's
ice cream you're like [__] you've never
tried before don't tell your parents
yeah you never had an avocado before
he's curating an entertainment
experience yeah
yeah it doesn't look nice he looks
amazing yeah but that's what a pita
would say yeah
she's also beautiful yeah that's crazy
but she likes him
right so she should be able to do what
she wants sure I mean you want everybody
obviously above you know above age he is
not he's he's my age he does not look
like a [__] 47 or 49 year old man he
looks like he's in his defense neither
do you
I'm saying it's [__] Leo what do you
want yeah no I of course well no one's
more Angry than at this than like a
middle-aged white woman oh sure if you
watch like you want to see some Fury
watch like the Ingram angle on TV and
she's like how dare he yeah now what if
he was dating she's pretty hot too Megan
Kelly's [__] Kelly's house
but what if he was dating a 19 year old
that was just Pig I mean fat like maybe
like good for him exactly exactly some
chick that works at Hot Topic I don't
think he gets it good for him on a 19
year old no matter what even on a fat 19
year old
he would be a savior
I think I think people are going to be
like what's he doing
well there'd be an angle it'd be an
angle but you know it's got a great
personality
you know if you're fat in a wheelchair
you better be sure you got to be
bringing it yeah he better not a singer
or something it's like full picture
that's when Charming [__] pigs
[Laughter]
was it the pick from
oh there
are from uh Green Acres Seinfeld does
that too though would you date a woman
20 years old and he's like you'd have to
be real vibrant yeah was it like shaking
the room or something like that yeah no
it was when she was when Elaine was
dating the guy uh who put cookies in his
mouth
that's another one a bad one too that's
another great off air you don't get to
see it but you hear the paramedics go
who put cookies in his mouth the
paramedics
with the chocolate yeah Larry David's
the vo and everything everything and he
kills it every time do you think that
was a reason of like do you it's funny
or like let me also just get this check
at the same time no I think yeah it's
he's in everything yeah he's the man of
the cape he was the guy that wouldn't
take the the the 20 with the lipstick
yeah that's right Steinbrenner yeah
Steinbrenner yeah that choice of
Steinbrenner is so funny just play it
that way he didn't like it Steinberg was
oh yeah on you know paper was like I
don't like it it's not funny
it's pretty damn funny it's terrible
really there's a there's deleted scenes
no [__] they said Larry David hated the
way he did it so he's like I'll do it
myself it was just such a perfect time
for New York and the Yankees yeah they
were just coming out of that it's hard
to be self-aware in a role like that
though that was a that was another thing
with Regis when Kramer went on he's
bonko Banco he didn't want to say bonkos
we say that all the time because we say
it all the time on the show he didn't
want to say bonkos because he's like I
wouldn't say this and and Larry's or
whoever was like you have to say but
it's Bonkers is that like because we're
not doing you we're doing a cartoon yes
yeah the cartoon of you says bonko of
course like you had and he was like I
don't want to say it and he's like you
have to [__] say bonka damn yeah and
that became I'm telling you this guy's
podcast it's funny because I'm sure it's
the Mandela effect or whatever it's
called I think that I heard Regis say
that before he was on the show
so much like something Regis would say
that's the thing the most Regis line
yeah fun fact seinfel has never said
what's the deal with he's never said
that in his act but it just became and
it sure became bigger than him
Sam I think he just said play it Sam I
don't think
yeah he was doing it on the show Kramer
did it too with the Styrofoam peanuts
yeah what are these things Bogart Bogart
didn't say that no one ever says play it
again yeah yeah you played it for her
you can play it for me yeah oh I love
that he's a [__] girl if she can take
it so can I yeah if she could take it
well he's not doing a lot of sports he's
getting these movies in who were you
before what'd you thinking what did you
never actually wow
Play It Again Sam if the boys are having
one I'll do whatever whatever's easy for
you spots same I got I gotta do a fight
I'm gonna show up to my show at the
seller drunk there you go
I got it I did one before this yeah
we're we're idiots oh again there's
nothing wrong with that might as well do
a Car Bomb thanks pal all right I mean I
mean while we're here do we only we have
Kahlua
you use Kahlua probably
which is a British it's a it's a bitter
beer yeah it's boddington's
something and what do we have in uh in
Epcot around the world have you ever
done that that's a fun thing you should
just do drinking around the world at
Epcot because they have all the
different countries whoa and the rule is
there's like dirt bags make a fun game
out of it of you have to they have like
one specialty drink in each country and
I think there's 11 countries
so you drink a drink in each country but
you're not allowed to take it to the
next country like you have to stay in
there and chug it good and I think we
have an 11. we had 11 drinks in like two
hours wow and it's like you're walking
you're like we had to be carried out it
was a great time beers or cocktails
whatever like you can get like a
Japanese beer or you can get like a
margarita like there's different ones
but what do we have at that English pub
was it wasn't harp it was something like
that though I think it was yeah yeah it
was pretty good damn
did you guys hear uh off brand off topic
Tom Brady's doing stand up it's probably
hilarious yeah that's good I think it
was a fake rumor dude come on well
didn't grunk do it a little bit Yeah
Gronk tried it for a second so did uh
what was what's the Asian lady from The
Today Show
great delivery
he's a funny guy he's a hunter he's a
very nice guy too he came into that show
and every female comic was like it was
wild I just want to see them be you know
inappropriate yeah
that's good but yeah Tom Brady everybody
wants to do stand up it's kind of
annoying that it's so easy to do stand
up because they just do it on a whim
like oh this is my [__] bucket list
thing I see that it's something that
yeah it's the click bait there's no way
he no I think I think it's uh he's doing
the Netflix for us
trying that [__] out gotcha who are they
roasting him oh okay okay I wouldn't do
anything
that's why Pamela Anderson did it it was
all donate to charity right did you
watch that documentary yeah it was
pretty pretty good jerked off yeah
all right
I'd still do it 100 yeah I keep telling
him it's a little inappropriate but I
keep telling him I think Britney is way
more attractive now than she was like I
like that Brittany pull up Spears oh I
like to make grinder
yeah pull up pull-ups man she's home
safe
she's definitely more available now
without that Dad you definitely have a
better chance yeah your chances are way
up she's just naked dancing around I
mean that's a really good picture like
if you her Instagram videos are pretty
rough
yeah they really she's a pretty woman
she's got like Meth mouth like it's like
she she hasn't you know what is meth
math it's just like her teeth are all
[__] up I don't know if she's really
doing meth she's
not flossing she's in the middle yeah
she's in the middle of a manic episode
for sure yeah you know her you know
she's not out of that conservatorship
and I don't think she should be in one
but when she got out I saw her vagina
within seconds the thing was out there
maybe maybe your dad was doing it it was
like she had it waiting to release yeah
not even like like she was like the
second this is up he might have been
running a tight shift yeah yeah well
loose lips
get clicks
all right
yeah she seems like a nightmare to hang
out with yeah we'd all like to I don't
know it could be a fun party
Tunes too you go through the greatest
hits she's got some of the hits are
great the hits are good Coca-Cola
sure they love it I like dude she's not
even a good dancer anymore which is
crazy yeah she really isn't she'd be
like what I would do if you wouldn't
dance I would do the same we gotta get
you in this outfit
I'm watching though I can't take my eyes
out it's mesmerizing
this is somebody's mom as far as
middle-aged moms what are we doing here
no of course of course that was your
neighbor
41.8 million followers crazy look she's
nuts dude and also with no music it
looks the way it works is it a music
player seriously she's having a stroke
but look she's having more fun than we
are Hotel crying do you think it's like
fun yeah she's having a blast she's on
top of she's so crazy she's on top of
the world right yeah I mean she can't
tell her anything she dances like Elaine
hahaha
she's dancing like a when you're
babysitting like a little girl you know
she's just twirling and [__] no I don't
know
wait when who's babysitting a little in
my restraining orders up
yeah this is a lot this is
yes yes that's what I'm saying it's like
kitty vibes
yeah this is
this is a tough following now she's
tired it's like a kid can you send me
that link please
wait who are these weirdos is that her
kids
they're better dancers than her yeah
they're good who are these guys I just
right now we're just watching tick tock
by the way I like how we were this is
like how addictive this [__] is sure we
just stopped talking yeah we're just
watching this [__] I forgot we were
doing a show good for you Brittany glad
you're happy
free Brittany also here's a peep of mine
the people who post their workouts
you're not inspiring people yeah I've
never seen someone in the gym been like
I gotta go to the gym and you're ruining
the gym now you got to set up a camera I
see this
there's going to be some pushback that
girl that like yells at Peach she tries
to get people it's like all clicks yeah
and it's like she'll be like oh this
person came over and harassed me they're
like they asked if you were using the
machine like yeah it wasn't they're not
trying to [__] you right well maybe they
are but yeah it's a little Burn yeah
yeah yeah I was being real subtle about
it she got Reef free canceled like she
tried to cancel some guys after her yeah
it's kind of nice to see I know it was
yeah Justice was yeah one for the good
guys you know what I mean yeah here here
now I can still creep on people at the
gym I don't like I don't like the uh
Road canceling so it's nice to see it
gone wrong yeah well she was just using
it to get her attention yeah the one guy
was like just standing there he's like
what I didn't even know you were there
no you're looking at it yeah yeah
like what the [__]
it's like it's like the gym you just
kind of want to be a lot you just want
to disappear of course
yeah the worst I mean have you had where
I'm on the the weight thing doing my
dumb curls with like five Pounders and
somebody's like comedy and I'm like hey
you
spot me real quick exactly
oh that's tough
what's the deal with your ellipticals
all right
do you guys have any peeves
um
putting back this heat in an airplane
the what whoa this we've been talking
about this is it putting the seat back
on an airplane it does it it does kind
of bug me the seat back thank you thank
you I'm a Batman I figured DSG give a
heads up no what if they got their tray
out they're eating what if they happen
to be a portly fellow and when the trade
comes back it jams them in their stomach
area well it knocks over their 15 Bloody
Mary the seat does go back nobody's
specific I don't want to ruin your night
but the seek reclines so I'm gonna use
it sure
I understand both sides of the argument
which does go back but it's also like I
don't like
I know how much it sucks when someone
comes back on me so I won't go back
unless the person behind me is back have
you been dropped up on that or you
weren't dropped back
I come back immediately right when the
wheels are off the Runway I drop it if
it is a morning flight I drop back
because I try to fall asleep immediately
sure but but I agree with you the food
thing when you drop back or how it [__]
up the whole TV situation it doesn't
Bend enough but then people can't get
out too it like jams them up if they're
trying to get out to go to the bathroom
or whatever you're all the way back you
immediately drop back immediately I hate
that really oh yeah I definitely I
figured I'd get it done early
you know uh I'm not gonna drop back
three hours into a six hour flight I'm
doing it right now just to set the table
that kind of makes sense somebody I
can't remember if I saw it online or
somebody told us this somebody drops
back
and they're being annoying about it you
take the air thing and point it right at
their head I like it I like the air
he's trying to go back further I just
don't if it reclines you it's like a
window shade you can put it up you can
put it down
but don't have people have ever annoyed
you with the window shade 100 there we
go that's the thing so it's like you
will annoy people there isn't there is a
an Ethics like when if if it's a morning
flight and it's cross-country or
something like that
sure everybody drops it down when they
have the it should be dictated by the
lights in the plane if all the lights
are off and it's shut down time he can't
be sitting there looking I do they
should be an all or nothing I do think
like when the seat belt like Hey we're
here the Wi-Fi clicks on it goes
everybody go back okay and then the last
guy in the back is [__] but he got bad
tickets yeah that's on him that's on him
but everybody every it should be an all
or nothing type that back row is a tough
situation tough luck man been back there
a lot yeah it's tough on every level
you're the last one off today yeah yeah
you're next to the bathroom tough look
it's just nothing about it's okay I'm I
I don't have to worry about the uh the
exit row I'm unqualified whoa because I
need a seat belt extent FAA regulations
found that out the hard way traveling
Biden says he's too fat to fly
I found that out the hard way traveling
with my lady oh we got a [__] exit
row extra leg room chilling out sit down
no problem they're like in the case of
emergency I'm like nope we'll take care
of it don't worry about it then she
walked back I was like hey can I get a
seat belt extender she was like
uh you're not allowed to sit in the exit
row if you need any seat belt extenders
or assistance so stands right there
and goes excuse me ladies and gentlemen
oh my God this gentleman can't sit in
the in the exit row is there anybody
that would voluntarily switch seats and
these two [__] studs stand up like ah
we'll take care of it ma'am and had to
switch Chris Hemsworth and uh yeah
literally yeah Rock [__] brutal holy
yeah you had to change their seat how to
move to their seat my nuts back and then
they [__] his girlfriend she wanted to
stay
these guys are cool so you had to walk
did you get up at least a little higher
up in the in the plane now further back
because it's higher up I don't think
he's going back had to pass him in the
aisle like thanks fellas thank you
appreciate your service yeah damn tell
my girlfriend I said hi
I'll try that next time there's a porker
up in there
but given
give it from LA or somewhere and you got
it on
yeah he was they were like sir you're
not allowed to sit there and we knew
that kind of going into it but someone
else booked the tickets for us so we got
they they were like oh we'll be nice you
got to got us the aisle or the yeah the
uh emergency exit there's a longer strap
so I was able to sweat it was like they
were like sir we just have to hear it it
was just click like we just need to hear
the click and then you can take it off
he's got it around his neck
holy [__] I'm sorry man is this I was
really rooting for it I was like man
just [__] let me hear that click just
get it in there with the end of Foley's
movie the last scene is you just hear it
clicking
slow clap starts on the play it's like
Cool Runnings is that what click is
about
damn I'm sorry but you're you're a
secure guy okay I don't give a [__]
you're good yeah he's not gonna cry
after this keep the cheddar biscuits
these are good all right give me a bite
of this
is it rival Popeyes because I grew up on
that [__] they're good I don't know I
don't think I've ever had Papa Popeyes
are all right with the put a little
butter and jelly on them oh talk to me
Daddy
good night
there's a place in um Rittenhouse Square
in Philly next time you guys are in
Philly called Devon Seafood I used to
work there when we were coming up they
do something similar to that
blow your brains out Devin's what Devon
Seafood it's right next to uh Park on
Rittenhouse Square be there soon
phenomenal biscuits
not good stuff Love A Biscuit oh yeah
they like cornbread your cornbread guy
cornbread I might have gone there with
Vito once Vita's such a [__] food
snob yeah I mean it's a corporate
seafood place but it's really good but
they're they just put those on the table
with apple butter or honey butter and I
think we went there I think veter picked
it out crushed it I got a doing Chicago
for my special taping I didn't realize
it's it's St Patty's Day weekend I'm
terrified no it'll be great it's a
taping they'll behave I'm talking Green
River beer River you know are you taping
on the 17th yeah Chicago have their own
wait is it a weekend yes I don't know
what I was saying it's gonna be Mayhem
that's like Christmas
yeah what been your agents have caught
that yeah nobody caught it don't they
have their own St Patty's Day in Chicago
might completely yeah but I think it's
like that's like the biggest thing
outside of Dublin is Chicago yeah it's
not like Canadian Thanksgiving where
it's in like July I've had some
bloodbath Chinese hecklers on I'm done
I've done same I've done Chicago and St
Patty's twice
this dude [__] nearly came to the
stage it got so heated it was ugly he
was a piece of [__] really yeah hmm it
was when Zanies used to make you do
three shows
and chakra it was on the 11 p.m I've had
that that wasn't a matinee that got you
yeah
oh yeah Bar Crawl God I hope none of
these animals are coming to the show
Friday 17th but no I'm sure fans know
probably right worst case you get a
[__] money ass takedown that's true
you get how many shots you've taken four
you're gonna get it buddy all right yeah
oh yeah yeah the pub crawls go from four
to ten so the show's at seven and you'll
be you'll be fine I think if your fans
are going they're not gonna hit the pub
crawl they're like they're gonna be like
we're going they know you're taping I
don't know we do a show called we might
be drunk we got a lot of Boozies we do
get boozy people man but they know
you're taping yeah Nobody's Gonna Wanna
bring it on the tape you're doing four
you're gonna get it okay okay
4 is a good number yeah and my man James
Webb is directing me you got that right
and uh we're doing Saturday too so maybe
I'll uh you'll be fine Vic [__]
look at that fun times but Evita's
opening and he's already hit me with
about 38.
I think we will yeah Seafood yeah that's
a great spot that's you're gonna love it
it's like old school Chicago
it's a little Steakhouse old school
attack real old school Italians by Gene
and georgetti's there's something about
steak with a side of pasta yeah it works
you feel like Jake LaMotta something
just I don't know what it is I want to
hit my wife
Chicago is a great City
number two comedy town in America what's
number one
Denver's great where's New York well New
York's up there but New York's already
so I think Philly's great I'm biased
Philly that's also the clubs are great
there too early San Diego Phoenix
uh Austin yeah San Diego we did a La
Jolla comedy so I [__]
yeah there's something about that stage
in La Jolla you feel it's carp it's
padded like a trampoline yeah it's
beautiful [__] great and they're
light on your toes five blocks away it's
like it's wacky yeah we're down in
basements with rats and Weirdos and you
know David tells got a black hood up and
then you go there it's Sunshine mountain
range and [__] yeah everybody's
attractive seals it's a great City and
it's a great City for comedy I mean but
Chicago there's something about Chicago
that I don't know man it's like also
that Capone bar is so [__] cool the
Green Mill have you been oh I love the
Green Mill I mean I'm by we're biased
because we're on the you know the
Eastern Seaboard River but Philly New
York yeah Austin's Grace Chicago DC's
Baltimore DC yeah it's just something
about
Baltimore's like Tampa can be [__]
fun I love daddies
we're coming back second show Brian
[__] Cleveland hilarities now we're
just named oh Cleveland's great yeah
Cleveland yeah I love Keith Wise Guys
but yeah Cleveland hilarity is another
one that's like you gotta throw out
Madison haven't been whoa yeah we're
trying to get it on the bus
here's a wreck while you're there and
this is just a wreck in general if you
go to a good farmer's market gotta hit a
good farmer's market he doesn't like a
farmer's market it's by cheese curds for
a block I'll do a pharmaceutical Market
it's a great uh biggest Farmer's Mark in
the country in Madison Wisconsin that's
all right what are you doing with the
fruit with the produce uh yeah
you bring it back no I don't bring it
back okay although although I did you
can bring it back some of them have like
hot sauces and if it's really good you
can order it online so I'll still
support it okay all right pull up Peach
with the red inside
Plum avocados not too soft I like Amanda
all right wait a minute Joe that was
pretty good girl the other one was he
came to me fiori said I forget his name
but uh it was Jake the Carl farman rep
the guy that worked for Carl Florida
oh I think I might have it one off Brett
the Jimmy
is a lot of these people come back in
the finale yeah
you're going two offices I was thinking
like Babu was pretty great he's been a
few yeah he was in the Dream Cafe and
then when he got deported right right
right in the finale yeah
what about like what about just a
straight up supporting character like
obviously not Newman but like third row
buddies up there oh putty's yeah putty's
family
uh peterman's great peterman's great
peterman's so good yeah
not in my office
Maestro is for Bob Cobb yeah it was
great hey zoc Doc there's nothing worse
than going to a doctor's appointment
having your doctor seem like they have
better places to be instead of checking
you out the doctor is checking the clock
not with zoc duck you'll find quality
doctors who focus on you listen to you
and prioritize you ZocDoc is the only
free app that lets you find and book
doctors who are patient reviewed take
your insurance and available when you
need them and treat almost every
condition Under the Sun choose from
thousands of patient reviewed doctors
and Specialists browse doctor profiles
up upload and verify your insurance
information and get the care you need go
to zocdoc.com drunk and download the
ZocDoc app for free then find a book
find and book top rated doctors today
many are available within 24 hours
that's z o c d o c.com slash drunk
zocdoc.com drunk get on it remember
sitting in your jammies watching
cartoons eating cereal be a kid again
with magic spoon I love this stuff it's
really good tasty had it yesterday when
I got off the road the fruity stuff I
like chocolate magic spoon gives you all
the flavor and crunch of a kid's cereal
that's healthy enough for adults yeah I
enjoy it I mean I like the peanut butter
the the caramel it's all good [__] oh
yeah here's what puts the Magic in Magic
spoon zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams
of protein and four to five net grams of
carbs in each serving only 140 calories
per serving you'll be going back for
seconds and thirds well you may be a kid
at hard your body still has adult needs
that's why magic spoon flavors are keto
friendly gluten-free grain free and soy
free don't know where to begin this
variety pack is the top four flavors
cocoa fruity frosted and peanut butter
click the link below and grab a variety
of magic spoon cereal and try today use
the promo code drunk at checkout to get
five dollars off any order or go to
magicspoon.com drunk magicspoon is so
confident in their product it's packed
with a 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they will
refund your money no questions asked so
click the link below or just scan the QR
code on the screen and use the code
drunk for five dollars off or go to
magicspoon.com drunk to save five bucks
today there we go can't wait to eat it
[Applause]
[Laughter]
a joke about mouth rape oral rape yeah
in Prime Time NBC
you anti-dentite son of a [__] they
should have their own schools oh Robert
Wagner is he in there oh yeah that's
right I think non-series regular but
heavy guest star Mickey Mickey was great
Mickey just showed up right he just
showed up just showed up all of a sudden
they were just boys they were just boys
oh I got a good Cameo Tony hey Tony hey
hey hey there's only supposed to be me
and Tony I know you don't like tuna fish
what are you 11. it's on Cameo it says I
met Mickey at Gotham once
you see his head shot at like really bad
sea level clubs I waited on him one time
in Philly at a Marathon Grill he was
down there for something with baseball
he was friends with like uh Tony
Hernandez
he was friends with somebody and I
remember I didn't realize it was him and
I walked up and he had his head down and
he's like I was like can I get you
something to start sir and he's like
I'll have coffee
shop
well this is gonna be a good promo for
this week anyway
all right boys well cheers what's that
what is this Jaeger is it
Oh I thought there was actually coffee
in it cheers
cheers boys
here we go 12 years so we're down to
drain
oh that's goddamn delicious that's all
right
one of the best Mickey moments
him and Kramer get into a fight he goes
you want to throw let's throw and then
they end they break up the fight and he
goes uh you know I work with uh Macaulay
Culkin he goes what's he like good kid
damn that's a [__] it's just
incredible how much it's weird because
overseas friends is so much bigger than
Seinfeld yeah let's show us the King of
Queens like Everybody Loves Raymond I
mean they remade that in other countries
what Everybody Loves Raymond right yeah
they tried they tried I thought they was
a documented they tried in uh Russia I
thought they did that it was seriously
called there's a he made a documentary
everybody loves Putin it didn't do well
I think it's called like everybody loves
Vladimir they were trying to
seriously something everybody loves
salad
the problem is Russia there's no love
they have no love well they didn't even
have a sitcoms so this was to launch
what a sitcom was oh it ran and people
couldn't wrap their heads around it oh
wow it's like that uh Family Guy the
Communists
they're like a bit solid
that's that's hilarious quit Stalin
Married with Children death of Stalin
good movie really yeah dude I don't
think I've seen it the guy it's a guy
who did Veep
you haven't seen V man the first couple
seasons of Veep [__] is that a joke a
minute
that's basically he's like you say no to
me again I hurt you that's how Stacy
keeps working he becomes Raymond in
Russia he just turns to the camera it
was then I knew my wife is that what was
the Linsky show what was that Paddington
Bear he was on a sketch show I think
yeah like he was like a variety comedian
like weird he was naked all the time
it's so broad their comedy out there I
mean no offense to non-americans but
they're kind of like you watch like
Mexican TV and it's just like a guy in
the Bumblebee soon very
um those are spicy of those those
Mexicans yeah those girls hot ladies
God but there's not a lot of British
people have some subtlety some uh yes
sure yeah smarter sarcastic yeah but
this Faulty Towers are You Being Served
Benny Hill Benny Hill was everybody's
intro into they used to rearrange the
letters on the Faulty Towers on the
intro of every episode at one time it's
a flowering plots no way pull it up I
never saw that one
my mom liked that show my mom watched
Night Court which they remade they're
coming back with yeah I know that's all
they do every show on TV can I say this
it's a tough look yeah what are we doing
what are you doing man what are you
[__] doing I mean it's sad that young
people like you know 22 year olds have
to watch the office because there's
nothing for them now
what's the show now sure you got like
South Park you got Family Guy
comedy-wise you mean yeah yeah sitcom
was no good sitcom what is it Superstore
or whatever the [__] that I didn't know
that like stranger things and [__] like
that yeah well they don't put a lot of
money in a comedy I feel like I know but
it was like we grew up on it like built
my childhood with these sitcoms I feel
like they're they they try to skip that
family aspect of people in their 30s
that settle down and are getting married
and starting families it's like before
or after Modern Family you know that was
that was that was a good show yeah it
was a great show for a while yeah it's
gone right but to sit down at a meeting
and be like let's remake Night Court
well half of the cast is dead no we're
gonna do we're gonna make your
girlfriend yeah that's what she's from
right get the [__] out of here Big Bang
Theory I'm drunk my buddy had a good
point he said uh they made the 90s show
that's a new show and there's a a gay
kid in it and they don't call them gay
the 90s that would not like that's not
the 90s yeah you had this great
advertising word to get away with
calling him a homo yeah
that doesn't make sense that 70 show was
pretty good the best yeah it was great
yeah I don't get it the original Night
Court forget about it oh yeah bull that
was a must-see TV that was cheers Corey
Anderson yeah maybe talk about taxi all
the time being in the house oh that was
great I mean James L Brooks is a [__]
man
I remember seeing taxi when I was real
young and seeing Danny DeVito and being
like holy [__] [__] that's comedy him
and Christopher Lloyd yes the first
episode I saw it was like 12 at night
and I couldn't fall asleep or something
like that I was probably like [__] 10
or 11 years old is when he eats the pot
brownies and becomes
he becomes Jim he was normal before that
oh is that right oh he's like at Harvard
or something like that and somebody has
to do a flashback and somebody has pot
brownies and all of a suddenly he goes I
was going like that I was like damn it
yeah that's good don't forget Andy
Kaufman on there forget about it of
course
he would come on as Tony Clifton and
just like get drunk slap a lady eat a
steak you know he just was all in Tony
Clifton was great for the longest time I
really thought he was alive who Andy
Coffee Daddy had faked it yeah for the
longest time that would be the ultimate
I have a hard time watching man on the
moon like makes me like genuinely sad I
know brutal
on uh Rodney's sketch show he's the only
guy to bring their character to life
yeah really uh what yeah he's laying in
the coffin and he's like you know like
the doctor's talking to his family and
he's like you think you think I feel bad
he owes me 55
now can I just say I'm now I'm drunk the
Long Island alumni in comedy is bananas
it's crazy David tell Rod oh Ronnie
might be Queens
[__] I think Rodney is but he was all in
Long Island he was at wasn't he aluminum
siding salesman Long Island I believe
you're right he was a long island act I
think then it's like
oh there you go Seinfeld
Seinfeld uh Schumer Opie and Anthony
um what's his face I think Eddie Murphy
Eddie Murphy was Long Island I think
Howard Stern not sure
yeah okay yeah no but for sure it's
crazy
what is a huge territory
yeah it's true it's like a very large
piece of life because New York City is
pretty crazy too it's like George Carlin
Rock uh Colin Quinn
yeah all these guys Geraldo Alexandro
Woody Allen Larry David yeah I mean New
York City
over here but I mean you got [__]
Jackie Gleason Gleason from uh Brooklyn
yeah I mean Giannis Christie yeah
but then Boston's no joke David I said
Larry Davis
killer Lewis yeah
Boston's crazy
it's Patrice Rogan stanho Burr Louie
Maron a little bit Oldman yeah it's
crazy Gary Goldman the goal
all right now I'm just listing all right
I love cities are we still recording we
should plug dates I mean you guys
obviously have the already garbage
podcast is amazing yeah we both been on
it we love it yeah every clip it pops up
is [__] hilarious thank you you guys
are killing it thanks buddy you want to
plug dates on tour yeah I got dates
coming in hot maybe we just started a
new tour of the stay trashy tour it
starts in the middle of uh March we're
going down to uh Timonium Maryland we're
doing magoobs but we're doing Virginia
Beach we got uh yeah we got Timonium
Virginia Beach Richmond Virginia
Oklahoma City Dallas Houston Austin
second show added New Haven Connecticut
adding a second show there Burlington
Vermont Tampa second show added Dania
Beach Florida I think it's called yeah
Raleigh Cleveland and Columbus that's a
good club it's outside Miami right yeah
Fort Lauderdale yes Fort Lauderdale
stand-up show and then at the end we
play a little ayg with the crowd it's a
fun thing oh that's a blast it's a great
live show you guys should really go see
it I love those added shows every cliff
in the live show it looks like so
[__] fun it's interesting it's a
really fun way to end the show because
like we each do stand up and then it's
like you just go dick around you know
what I mean it's like super fun I mean
how happy you guys found a thing and it
it just clicked yeah it was so uh
relatable and whatnot it's very uh very
crazy yeah yeah we're very excited very
fortunate shout out to the bozos and the
homies we're past these dates already I
gotta update my website this is on HTML
or HDMI or uh I don't know what that is
but uh yeah yeah come on out
uh the Vic recording's probably over
because this is St Patty's Day
oh it does all right well hey coming to
Chicago the Vic theater then I'm in uh
[__] Toledo and then I'm back uh
laugh it up and then doing uh Oxnard
improv in LA and then it's back on the
theater tour that we're going to
Australia we're going to UK we're going
all in I love that so come take over so
we got the bus tours starting this week
another bus leg baby we're doing a Miami
Orlando uh all over Ponte Vedra Atlanta
Charleston Durham Charlottesville
Norfolk DC uh wilkesbury Port Chester
San Diego La Sacramento San Francisco
more coming like Cincinnati Columbus all
that [__] Crest is a beauty Portland
Maine we're coming back down from
Portland Maine so I'm hitting a lot of
places going back down on another leg so
yeah bring the Vader bring always bring
in the theater you got a bus we're doing
a bus sick man congratulations congrats
please yeah oh yeah please sorry Joey
roses I'm there during the week
sometimes on the weekends uh hook me up
on Instagram that's what I know but I'm
sitting here there we go
yeah yeah front good to see you buddy
for St Patrick's Day I'm also a musician
I'll be out at the Red Lion on St
Patrick's Day oh I love the red line I
was there the other night on Bleaker
yeah whoa
at the red lion and a guy walks over
buys me and my lady a drowned who's in
the band hey I was like I'll [__]
take it man that's pretty much from like
8pm to four wow wait spasmatic that's
problematic
and he's an addict all right
all right well okay check him out thanks
man thanks Patrick well this has been an
awesome episode thank you guys thank you
so much man this is a fun and uh happy
Saint Patty's happy St Patty's have a
great one guys
[Music]
what'd you say I was gonna say the day
that St Patrick chased the Dominicans
out of Ireland
[Laughter]
um
[Music]
dangerous
I'm out to lunch here in New Orleans
this woman doesn't look like I remember
her and I get down in the same way
[Music]